questi ragazzi e benvenuti mamma abbiamo
solo gasato del virus abbiamo fatto sto
gioco un sacco di tempo fa tipo nel 2017
prima ancora che uscisse signor tv si
chiama black wade ed era una demo la
demo della demo della demo è uscito tre
anni dopo quindi al 2020 può fare anche
i calcoli incredibile e ho voluto
provare in live con leo e mickey che
sono i miei capitani d'ordinanza si dice
questa cosa non allora mi metto io buona
visione ragazzi già è bellissimo è
veramente incasinato c'è il bisognerebbe
giocare con gente che sa quello che sta
facendo
l'altra anche cannoni dietro questa nave
incredibile come dicevo prima ci ha
pensato sempre in si opti ci siamo vi
sono dai vai vai avanti avanti avanti
avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti
il bello è che non puoi girare karaman
oggi aree testa di io non vedo neanche
questo spara a lato poi spara dalla nave
all'altra non ha un senso non vedi
niente
c'è poi a culo pieno che devi fare
quando quando gli spinto al cannone
verso il buco devi fare look è tipico
spa colmo si ritrova stiamo riguardando
un sacco di a cuore a quando tu spingi
il cannone leo è che i pentiti se tu ti
avvicini ai premi e subito il look
forse sì l'ho fatto era solo che non ho
mai l'angolo per spara sul galeone
quando si va bene la tonaca club le vele
ragazzi siamo un po nel a me qualcuno
faccia delle cose cristo
io sto guardando un meritorio parando
buchi ma ne abbiamo cinque sto facendo
tutta la sola e siamo affondati
io sto rispondendo ora sto sto
picchiando morti fortissimo gli abbiamo
dato ok sono rimasto ucciso barney
stinson comunque non li vedo i buchi
quel fatto capito che dipendere martello
in mano per avermi il martello diventano
rossi buchi ok
e anche le belle possono dare ai
problemi è perfetto e proprio sono
riuscito a riparare a posto sulla nave
quanto stiamo facendo schifo da 1 a
mille
1047 fa scattare la gente padana se ho
fatto una kill non sono anche quando la
come mi dice me la gente sulla nave che
che si spara fortissimo e qualcuno ogni
tanto si beve il tè dalla tazzina esatto
una kg fatto si è strano questo tutti i
bravi però tutti che mettono subito
valle della gente ma come ha fatto a
fare una kill ma quando l'ho fatta morto
sette volte capitano della vittoria
questo gioco manco fossero è detto e ci
pensa lui signor nando vada vada signore
i player pur di chi sa di che canale
gigantesca questa mi pare la nostra ma
non c'e neanche scritto
questa è la smetta non è questa qua e
captain and black out 2010 ma non sei
capitano si 6 capitano dal capitano
cannibal care non è questa a naturale di
creare porca vacca devenuto e l'ex paura
di farci una rete di venire qua divenire
cabina zigari the ship c'è il tizio che
vende le navi ok è esatto e che noi
stavamo donare un altro capitolo è
berlusconi che come come come questo qua
struttura che non volete la già anche la
caccia della favola che quanto tempo per
far dire ok ragazzi ci stiamo pagando
non so come si tirano giù le vele però
non fa niente in fondo dove sviluppa
all'orizzonte cosa strana qua o un buco
in buco in buco e tranquilla provata
garantito la adesso
quello che ti dicevo che il bot non
stando a un cazzo bene propria crisi non
c'è più non lo vedo c'è non c'è più dove
si registra anche assistita da spalla a
fare lo come le cose lì dove succede
l'angolo non cassano
qual è la sua destra sto gira col freno
a mano e va bene qui l'ater loc
non diventerà ancora ancora ancora
ancora ancora ancora ancora non li
prendo sennò che risparmiamo se i buchi
raga non va benissimo a morte non sono
anche se non credo di averli colpiti
continua a morire io ma come durica
giusto cammino si fa creato il culo
abelli ramon richiamo 8 buchi adesso
mortaio a mano dando ship col teatro
rasi va bene e affondati saliamo insomma
verifica come cacchio sale o insultando
malissimo
va bene immagino non li vedono rivedono
vinciamo grappo lati
io non li vedo neanche dove sa che
abbiamo grappo lati noi è troppo lo dico
mi caricano non li vedo non a caso le
grappe the man in vita
no no no no perché l'acido bailado
abbordarla hai abbandonato la con ale ma
cosa ti sto portando ma che cazzo ha
ucciso tre persone erano noti sono solo
per i loro io pure io pure lo ha ucciso
voleva sparate da uno sbaglio il compito
lando colpito e ucciso violet paul
italiano ma no sono giusti
così oggi i simpson signor marco
borriello
grande lo abbiamo buttato giù tutto sono
tornati i numeri che lavorando grande
quindi la picchiare perché ho
abbandonato la nave va sotto deficiente
non so come si gioca il gioco ai giovani
co2 lasciava dubbi dagli esperti
veramente abbiamo pagato la nave ci ha
detto che stava abbandonando la nave non
indietro a quello che chigi la sinergia
tra ci andiamo c'abbiamo cin ancora un
pochino con un po non ha girato
ecco la sua destra e ho capito che non
so che dire allora io sto guardando dai
ha finalmente si misurarono labbra tra
le quaranta taranta antara run tanta la
rara carantan taranta entra run tanta
roba da garante da ferrando sta
condannando la gara sarà mai mi era
capitato a segnare il cappio anaya per
una sinistra gas così che cosa sinistra
ma io sono su un'altra nave ho sbagliato
sono sulla rami fiction io sono sei mesi
fa non siamo affondati raga poi siete
ammontati a navene bianco
me ne sono andato perché affrontaste
probabilità lite su quella di bianco il
mio capitano è stato ucciso che castrano
su un'altra nave
io gioco con i suoi stati lì perché sono
giocatori esperti per quando come
aicardi che cosa sia in questo grock da
14 certamente adesso ce l'ho a tiro
adesso io non c'era un paradiso corano
la messaggio no se ne semisa
un'astronave fondi pai oppure timi chi
ha scritto uno dei nostri grande
chicchini chi gira gira girano gira non
possono colpire ma qualcuno lo spot il
nemico perché non vedo i nemici a
cambiarmi loadout questo davanti al
nemico
non ho idea di questo davanti al nemico
sua sinistra
le stesse la sinistra e nemmeno colpiamo
con i cannoni questo qua è tutto più it
ho preso un gruppo lesti quando a destra
destra adesso dai raggi ancora un po lo
riprendo non gira non ci metto zio
vetritto devi andare bisogna barca via
ok ok morto proposta non sopporto oh
cazzo loro paioletti land airbus ha
ucciso un altro club l'ha ucciso bla bla
bla
il plateau 5 io come la di dover
incornati alle armi aiuto in mano non
solo deciso ai cugini o non mi trova la
città considerando ha ucciso tutti noi
facciamo schifo sappia qual era la spada
mannaia come son morto ma come son morto
ma non ha portato a mano
no ragazzi dobbiamo mettere roma nei
cannoni vi prego perché da tempo non può
dire così non può sfuggire ancora
lavorando
gira bene di gravi sto giro ma non
giravano cerchino serviti più colpiti o
colpi di lancia da lì stava grappa
maledizione cd quasi abbiamo due buchi e
ragazzi riparo 146 bucchi abbiamo a caso
due stent e il capitano è stato ucciso
io vado a poco mi butto in acqua per
spegnerlo perché astori per astori però
la l'aveva essere varate le vene vedere
che cosa facciamo bene
e bellissimo abbiamo vinto il nostro
però abbiamo privatevi in vincono
aspetta sì mi sa di sì e no era l'anno
eravamo i pirati che la voleva sempre
gli altri
va bè ragazzi questa rabbia è quake
molto carino secondo me ma molto
confusionario fatemi sapere solo
preferita si opti so se volete un altro
episodio su questo non se volete si opti
so se non volete niente o se volete che
io mi taglio i capelli o qualsiasi altra
cosa ragazzi di tema e noi ci vediamo
come sempre a un prossimo video bella
ragazza
[Musica]